Dear fellow scholars. This is too many papers with Dr. [inaudible] today.
We are going to play with a cellular automaton.
You can imagine these automata as small games,
where we have a bunch of cells and a set of simple rules that describe when a
cell should be full and when it should be empty.
These rules typically depend on the state of the neighboring cells.
For instance,
perhaps the most well-known form of the cellular automaton is John Horton.
Conway's game of life,
which simulates a tiny world where each cell represents a little life
form the rules. Again, depend on the neighbors of this cell.
If there are too many neighbors, they will die due to overpopulation.
If too few, they will die due to under population.
And if they have just the right amount of neighbors,
they will thrive and reproduce. So why is this so interesting?
Well,
the cellular automaton shows us that a small set of simple rules can
give rise to remarkably complex life forms such as gliders,
spaceships, and even John four, nine months universal constructor,
or in other words, self-replicating machines.
I hope you think that's quite something. And in this paper today,
we are going to take this concept further way further.
This cellular automaton is programmed to evolve a single cell to grow
into a prescribed kind of life form. Apart from that,
there are many other key differences from other works,
and we will highlight two of them today. One,
the sad state is a little different because it can either be empty
growing or mature.
And even more importantly to the mathematical formulation of the problem
is written in a way that is quite similar to how we train the deep neural
network to accomplish something. This is absolutely amazing.
Why is that? Well, because it gives rise to a highly useful feature,
namely that we can teach it to grow these prescribed organisms,
but weight over time, some of them seem to decay.
Some of them can stop growing and some of them will be responsible for
your nightmares. So from this point on proceed with care
in the next experiment,
the authors describe an additional step in which it can recover from these
undesirable States.
And now hold onto your papers because this leads to one of the major points of
this paper. If it can recover from undesirable States,
can it perhaps regenerate when damaged,
well here you will see all kinds of damage and then this
happens. Wow.
The best part is that this thing wasn't even trained to be able to perform this
kind of regeneration.
The objective for training was that it should be able to perform its task of
growing and maintaining shape.
And it turns out some sort of regeneration is included in that
it can also handle rotations as well, which will give rise to a lot of fun.
And as noted a moment ago,
some nightmarish experiments and note that this is a paper in the
distill journal, which not only means that it is excellent,
but also interactive. So you can run many of these experiments yourself,
right in your browser.
If Alexander Marvin serve the name of the first author rings a bell,
he worked on Google's deep dreams, approximately five years ago,
how far we have come since my goodness loving these crazy
non-traditional research papers.
And I'm looking forward to seeing more of these.
This episode has been supported by weights and biases here.
They show you how you can visualize the training process for your boosted trees
with XG boost using that tool. If you have a closer look,
you'll see that all you need is one line of code weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments in your deep learning projects.
Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI toured our research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you're an academic or have an open source project,
you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get a freedom all today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.